one of the unexpected upsides of stress
is it's surprising linked to meaning in
life a few years ago study was released
by the world Gallup poll that actually
looked at what they called the stress
index of 121 countries where they went
around the world and they asked people
did you experience a great deal of
stress yesterday and they had expected
the research is expected that having a
country of people who were stressed out
that that would be related to really
terrible things you know less happiness
with life less satisfaction with life
you know worse health shorter life
expectancy but they found instead is
that if you have a nation of people who
say yesterday was really stressful you
have a nation of people who also are
happier there more satisfied with their
lives they also tend to live longer and
one of the reasons seems to be that the
things that create stress in our lives
are also the things that create meaning
that same Gallup world poll found that a
high stress index was associated with a
greater chance that you would say you
learn something interesting yesterday a
greater chance that you experience joy
love laughter yesterday and a more
recent study done here in the United
States found that if you want to know
whether or not someone has a meaningful
life the best way to find out is to ask
them about the stress in their lives
that people who say their lives are more
meaningful they tend to experience more
stress in their past they tend to be
under more stress currently they spend
more time thinking about the
difficulties they've overcome and they
also spend more time worrying about the
future and it again seems to be because
the things in our lives the
relationships the roles the difficult
goals that we're pursuing the things
that create meaning also inevitably
create stress and a simple example of a
mindset reset that's been shown to
really change the way people experience
the most distressing moments is to bring
to mind the value that is sort of most
relevant to the stressful situation to
give you an example last night I was on
a flight coming back from Georgia it was
crazy thunderstorms here in New York and
we had a really difficult landing and
I'm someone who hates flying
I'm afraid of flying I hate turbulence I
get motion sickness it was just a
disaster and I'm literally like holding
on to my seat and holding onto the side
of the window trying to stay in my seat
despite the fact that I'm strapped in
and what helps in those moments is to
remember two to two of my values one is
courage that every time I get an
airplane I am demonstrating that this is
something I care about to to actually
express courage that I can help other
people be brave and also to recognize
that I value what travel gives me in
life that I value the fact that I was
able to go and meet with people who work
in health care and talk to them about
behavior change so that they might
support health and well-being and others
now I value being able to go places even
if in the moment of the flight it's
incredibly distressing and bringing
those things into the distressing
moments seems to really protect people
from the typical sort of negative
effects of those big moments of distress
where you're you know you'd rather be
anywhere else or you are starting to
lose hope in your situation